what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson we have the thor
love and thunder trailer the full
trailer where i'm hoping we're gonna get
our first look at gore i'd be surprised
if they didn't let's not waste any time
ow
gonna keep that in there let's not waste
any time let's go ahead and watch this
trailer right now because i am super
excited let's go
kids get to pop corner let me tell you
the story of the space viking
he was no ordinary man
he was a god
after saving planet earth for the 500th
time thor set off on a new journey
well he got in shape
he went from dead bod
to god
and after all that
he reclaimed his title
one and only four
oh spook too soon
jane
his helmet
the old ex-girlfriend
what's the family three four years eight
years seven months and six days
am i uh sensing feelings
[Music]
well you're right
the only ones who gods care about
is themselves
so this is my vow
all gods will die
okay
i got one of those i was going to say
that was very very impressive what you
did back there
it's just my first bad guy
[Music]
because i first something worth fighting
for
[Music]
yes
so let's see who you are i take off your
disguise russell grow and flick
oh you flick too hard damn it
[Laughter]
should we help him eventually great
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right you know i'm getting major
like grandmaster vibes there at the end
you know because how thor was you know
held down and captive before and forced
to be a gladiator against the hulk
that's kind of what it looked like major
vibes from there like i thought they'd
go to olympus because he would know zeus
but maybe not maybe he's just going to
ask for some help her to find out what's
going on about gore
because gore looked fantastic thor going
gonna need something more than
stormbreaker to take on gore and i think
he's gonna need the help of jane foster
and mjolnir which he's gonna get
i think gore looks fantastic i was
really worried when we saw some of like
the leaked toys and everything like that
i was like oh not so sure this looks
great actually i i really like this i
heard he looks pretty menacing and hey
it lives up to it
thor ragnarok is like my third favorite
mcu film so i'm hoping this get this
gives it a major run for its money
i think it will i think this is going to
be an amazing film but let me know what
you all think in the comments down below
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe and hit that bell so you don't
miss out on any of the latest videos
including the breakdown which is going
to come right now i'm going gonna start
work on it right now so i'll catch you
guys in just a bit woof